what would be the main differences that
we would hear on Amber's BD calls early
on to more recently and more now so 2018
Amber Business Development calls were
all about me it was III Irving like this
Irving Knight that I'm a recruiter in
this I'm a recruiter in that whereas now
I want to eradicate I from my vocabulary
it's all about them it's about their
pain points it's about their Journey
it's about why did you take call with me
today what are you looking for it's
about them it's not about me and again
that comes down to 80 years 20 mouth and
again I think that's a huge mistake that
I made at the start I was just talking
and blurting out all of these ideas
again to prove to them that I knew what
I was talking about when in reality that
proof came from my questions rather than
the things that I had rehearsed and
blurted out to them and the rehearse
script that I had about Irving Knight
and why we were amazing when in reality
they don't really care about our new
shiny CRM they don't care about the fact
that I've got thirty thousand candidates
in our database in San Diego they don't
care they care about if I can solve
their problem and if I've done it before
more importantly so again I think I've
been now weaving previous placements and
the solution that I provided to that
company into my questioning so
throughout the business development call
I'm throwing in oh typically VPS at
whatever company you're experiencing
that as well we did this project for
them and it equated to X solution so
just kind of involving old placements to
increase the familiarity and therefore
the buying power when you finish that
business development call the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincere and the
award-winning Source breaker